[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ils sont contents moi aussi c'est déjà
cette gagner donc oui on est c'est
plutôt agréable je pense qu'il faut plus
que ça c'est pas assez ça descend des
prix mais c'est bien si on regarde les
prix comme ça c'est bien
[Musique]
au cœur de Londres des salariés heureux
comme une soixantaine d'autres cette
entreprise britannique attestée avec
succès pendant 6 mois la semaine de
quatre jours au lieu de 5 avec un
salaire maintenu à 100%
les gens sont plus énergiques au travail
il commence leur semaine le lundi après
avoir eu trois jours de repos
personnellement j'ai ressenti les
avantages à la maison en ayant plus de
temps pour ma famille et pour mon
nouveau chien tu as intérêt à pas
oublier qu'il y a une machine parce que
si tu vas pour ouvrir
[Rires]
c'est en fait il a repris la voix
d'Eminem qui m'a fait un générer par un
ordinateur et il a ajouté dans un de ses
morceaux on écoute ce que ça donne
c'est pas Eminem qui qui chante là c'est
une voix qui avait été générée par
ordinateur
[Musique]
c'est super
pas plus tard qui ressort le chanteur
donné à concert à Lille pour son retour
dès le début il a bien prévenu le public
qui voulait pas être filmé qu'il voulait
pas être pris en photo en plus les
réseaux sociaux il déteste ça et ça n'a
pas arrêté très très vite les téléphones
ont été dégainés il a même vu s'arrêter
en plein milieu d'une chanson pour leur
dire de baisser les téléphones peut-on
parler à voix haute au cinéma le débat a
été lancé sur internet il y a quelques
jours par la pop star suédoise Zara
Larsson pour elle c'est le principe même
d'aller voir un film à plusieurs on
partage la même expérience on rit on
crie on analyse les personnages pendant
qu'on regarde la chanteuse est
minoritaire mais soutenue par son
compatriote le réalisateur Ruben osloon
mais il est pas le seul en avoir marre
de cette marée de lumière bleue Jack
White c'est le chanteur des White strap
s'il est allé très loin parce qu'elle
impose même à l'entrée de ses concerts
des espèces de pochettes qui sont
scellées dans lesquelles les téléphones
sont obligatoirement rangés Zara Larsson
a finalement supprimé sa vidéo et
quelques jours plus tard de retour du
cinéma il y avait deux personnes
derrière nous elle n'arrêtait pas de
parler elle a même changé un peu d'avis
jamais je ne dérangerai quelqu'un
volontairement un accord se restera à
l'écart de tout ça et puis on va avoir
des températures qui vont commencer à
baisser
cet après-midi fera souvent 9 à 13
degrés
reprenez votre souffle qu'est-ce que je
peux faire qu'est-ce que je peux faire
Géraldine
on arrive au demander au chauffeur de
sortir du véhicule et là mais moi je
donne tout
[Musique]
ton mois ton mois
et tricote tricote
pas
tout le monde
non c'est clair c'est une évidence
et je vois le mec partir et je me dis
mais je suis trop con à la main ça
crache ces injections Mahé les a réalisé
dans un cabinet clandestin il y a deux
mois
séduite par ses photos avant et après
son injectrice facture 180 euros les
lèvres deux fois moins que chez un
médecin
tellement ému merci beaucoup restez sur
France 5 une soirée science grand format
celle de Mathieu vida comme tous les
mercredis soir ce soir on part au jeudi
on est jeudi
préfériez pas qu'elle aille chez un
médecin alors pour tout vous dire je
savais même pas que les médecins
faisaient ça parce que pour moi c'est
pas de la médecine ça c'est la médecine
esthétique mais c'est pas de la médecine
elle est pas malade quoi c'est
l'esthétique aujourd'hui un institut de
beauté oui le médecin j'aurais pas cru
mais qu'est-ce que ça veut dire on se
dégaler
la Vierge Marie en fait d'accord il vous
appelle la Vierge Marie votre mari oui à
mon avis vous avez peut-être deux trois
points communs mais des choses qui vous
différencient à mon avis je pense hein
sans aller trop trop loin dans les
explications chacun comprendra ce qu'il
veut
[Rires]
et voilà je suis censée conclure là déjà
oh on avait presque envie de revoir
encore plein d'images